you have so much love in your life
you radiate love
do you ever feel lonely
so I there's different types of people
some people drain in Gatherings some
people recharge in Gatherings I'm
definitely the recharging type
I'm an extremely uh social creature I I
recharge with intellectual exchanges I
recharge with physical exercise I
recharging nature uh but I also can feel
fantastic when I'm the only person in
the room that doesn't mean I'm lonely it
just means I'm the only person in the
room
and I think
there's a secret to not feeling alone
when you're the only one and that secret
is self-reflection it's introspection
it's almost watching yourself from above
and it's basically just
becoming yourself becoming comfortable
with the freedom that you have
when you're by yourself
so hanging out with yourself I mean
there's there's a lot of people who
write to me who talk to me about feeling
alone in this world
that struggle especially when they're
younger Is there further words of advice
you can give to them when they are
almost paralyzed by that feeling so I
sympathize completely and I have felt
alone and I have felt that that feeling
and what I would say to you is
stand up
stretch your arms just like become your
own self just like realize that you have
this freedom
and breathe in
walk around the room take a few steps in
the room just like get a feeling for the
3D version of yourself
because very often we're kind of stuck
to a screen and that's very limiting and
that sort of gets us in particular
mindset but activating your muscles
activating your body activating your
your full self is one way that you can
kind of get out of it and that is
exercising your freedom reclaiming your
physical space
and one of the things that I do is I
have something that I call me time which
is if I've been really good all day I
got up in the morning I got the kids to
school and made them breakfast I sort of
you know hit the gym I I had a series of
really productive meetings I reward
myself with this me time and that that
feeling of sort of when you're
overstretched to realize that that's
normal and you just want to just let go
that feeling of exercising your freedom
exercising your me time
that's where
you free yourself from all stress you
basically say it's not a need to anymore
it's a want to
and as soon as I click that me time all
of the stress goes away and I just bike
home early and I get to to my work
office at at home and I Feel Complete
freedom but guess what I do without
complete freedom I just don't go off and
drift and do boring things I basically
now say okay
this is just for me I'm completely free
I don't have any requirements anymore
what do I do I just look at my to-do
list and I'm like you know what can I
clear off
and if I have three meetings scheduled
in the next three half hours it is so
much more productive for me to say you
know what I just want to pick up the
phone now and call these people and just
knock it off one after the other and I
can finish three half hour meetings in
the next 15 minutes just because it's
the want not I have to
so that would be my advice basically
turn something that you have to do in
just me time stretch out exercise your
freedom and just realize you live in 3D
and you are
a person and just
do things because you want them not
because you have to noticing and
reclaiming the freedom
that each of us have that's what it
means to be human if you notice that
you're truly free
physically mentally psychologically but
Noah's you're an incredible human uh we
could talk for many more hours we
covered less than 10 percent of what we
were planning to cover but we have to
run off now to the uh social Gathering
that we spoke of we're 3D humans we're
3D humans and reclaim the freedom I
think I hope we can talk many many more
times there's always a lot to talk about
but more importantly you're just a human
being with a big heart and a and a
beautiful mind that people love hearing
from and I certainly consider a huge
honor to know you and to consider your
friend thank you so much for talking
today thank you so much for talking so
many more times and thank you for all
the love behind the scenes that you send
my ways it always means the world Lex
you are a truly truly special human
being and I have to say that I'm honored
to know you I have like so many friends
are just in awe that you even exist that
you have the ability to do all the stuff
that you're doing and uh I I think
you're a gift to Human Manatee I love
the mission that you're on to sort of
share knowledge and insight and deep
thought with so many special people who
are transformative but people across all
walks of life and and I think you're
doing this in just such a magnificent
way I wish you strength to continue
doing that because it's a very special
Mission and it's a very training Mission
so thank you both the human you and the
Robert you the human you for showing all
this love and they rob with you for
doing it day after day after day so
thank you Lex all right let's go have
some fun let's go